Rona santis also making big moves down
in Florida he has ordered Florida
schools to shut down the students for
justice in Palestine groups Governor Dan
santis directed Ry Rodriguez who's the
chancellor of the State University
system of Florida to send notices to UF
and University of South Florida
notifying them to deactivate chapters of
students for justice in Palestine and
the reason for this DeSantis argues is
that those groups broke Florida laws
about terrorism here's what Des Santa
said during a holy Jewish holiday the
which is a little repetitive right
holiday is a holy day anyway I'm
nitpicking on language during a holy
Jewish holiday the recognized terrorist
organization Hamas launched an
unprovoked attack on Israel among those
killed were babies women and elderly oh
this is Rodriguez who said this uh to
date approximately 1400 israelies have
been killed including 31 American
citizens Governor Dan santis our State
University system and the Florida
college system have condemned these
attacks there are
some conservatives here who are
attacking DeSantis for doing this and
they're attacking Dan santis because
they say this is an attack on Free
Speech I think what Dan santis is doing
in principle is terrific I think this is
great in fact this is exactly the sort
of thing that I call for in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds number one National bestseller
available for you to order right now
wherever fine books are sold this is
exactly the sort of thing that I'm
calling for in speechless my only hold
up I didn't even catch myself saying it
that time
speechless no you guys were slow you
didn't expect the third one I got to get
those producers a little faster my only
hold up on what Governor Dan santis is
doing here
is it doesn't go far
enough my only hold up here is this is
the first time this is a relatively
modest way for conservatives to begin
wielding political and cultural power to
shape norms and standards in principle I
think it is a perfectly fine thing to do
for the state to pass laws
against in this case taxpayer subsidized
support for speech promoting
terrorism but does it only apply to
Hamas and Israel this is the only time
we're going to use this kind of a law
when it when it applies to Pro Palestine
protest
what about pro antifa and pro BLM
protesters antifa is a terror
organization I say this having been the
target of antifa on at least one
occasion when they tried to blow me up
at the University of Pittsburgh last
spring antifa exists to Target and harm
and kill
civilians to achieve political
objectives that is as basic a definition
of terrorism as it is so are we going to
shut down student groups who support
antifa I hope so I hope they use this
law for that purpose what about BLM BLM
is a terror organization it's a little
bit of a harder argument with BLM
because their rhetoric at least is
somewhat softer but BLM in
practice exercised terrorist campaigns
on the United
States BLM in practice attacked
businesses looted robbed killed people
killed dozens of people attacked
civilians to achieve a political
objective that is the most basic
definition of terrorism that is so are
we going to see the government come in
and clamp down using this kind of a law
on BLM I hope
so this is this is a good thing in
principle but if it only applies to this
narrow conflict of Israel versus
Palestine then it seems very suspect it
seems it seems to be haphazardly and and
only narrowly enforced but it's a good
principle the conservatives who are
attacking Dan santis over some attack on
free spee speech or whatever they're
they're misguided here in principle this
is the right thing in principle this is
what conservatives have always done this
is what all societies do because all
societies have standards and Norms this
is certainly what the left has done
toward ends of Injustice and evil we
should use these sorts of tactics in a
just and moral way to achieve good ends
and political flourishing we just got to
do it more often and in more
circumstances now this letter from
Governor D santis and the chancellor of
the Florida State system uh it's a good
letter but when you want to write and
send letters you got to check out
stamps.com right now go to stamps.com
use promo code NES if you run a small
business you need to plan ahead one of
the best ways to do that is by using
stamps.com for all your mailing and
shipping needs stamps.com lets you print
your own Postage and shipping labels
right from your home or office space
this is incredibly convenient your
shipping labels are ready to go in
minutes so you can get back to running
your business sooner we don't waste time
here at the daily wire we don't have
time to waste time time we've used
stamps.com since
2017 when many of you were nothing but a
glint in your father's eye that's right
our office management staff loves
stamps.com because they don't have to
spend hours at the post office anymore
stamps.com offers rates you can't find
anywhere else like up to 84% off USPS
and UPS plus they will automatically
tell you your cheapest and fastest
shipping options for 25 years stamps.com
has been indispensable to over 1 million
businesses you can print postage
wherever you do business no lines no
traffic no waiting they even send you a
free scale so you've got everything you
need to get started set your business up
for Success get started with stamps.com
today sign up with promo code nolles KES
for a special offer that includes a
four-week free trial plus free postage
and a free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts go to
stamps.com Click the microphone at the
top of the page enter code nolles
kwes now speaking of
schools I alluded to this earlier in the
show uh billionaire Ron Lauder of Estee
Lauder has just threatened to pull
funding from upen over Up's Embrace of
anti-Semitism Ron
Lauder is a republican Mega donor he
gives a lot of money to upen his Alma
Moder he's the president of the world
Jewish Congress which is an
international organization and he had
already said to pen that he was going to
reexamine his donations here because
upen seems to be allowing these these
students to support Hamas over the state
of
Israel once again there are some
conservatives here who are saying well
that's that's crazy we need to support
Free Speech even if the students want to
go out and support Hamas or something
like that I think though I I see this
move from Ron Lauder I think this is
brilliant of course the only thing I'm
somewhat scandalized by is why was this
guy giving money to upen in the first
place Ron Lauder is a Conservative
Republican Ron Lauder shouldn't be
supporting the ivy league I mean listen
I don't want to tell billionaires what
to do with their money but there are a
lot of conservative donors who do this
who because they're alumni of schools or
because they've had some relationship
with an institution in the past they
just give money reflexively they got a
lot of money to give it's a rounding
error for them but those organizations
aren't what they used to be they've
become very leftist in recent years and
sometimes the donors don't even realize
it and in this case Ron Lauder a a
Jewish donor is noticing it because the
institution is
now encouraging students to support
Hamas and because the ivy league broadly
has a problem of professors now
supporting Hamas and Lauder says okay
well I'm pulling my money I think I
think it's the right thing to do for
Lauder to pull his money but I would go
further I think all conservatives should
be acting this way and not only on the
issue of Israel Palestine they should be
acting this way on all sorts of issues
it's not as though universities are just
now uniquely attacking the Jewish state
universities for years for decades have
attacked white people they they've held
courses and seminars about how we need
to abolish whiteness why are white
people still giving money to the
universities the universities have come
out explicitly and said we don't like
white people we think it's bad to be a
white person we want to punish white
people we want to discriminate against
white people as a matter of University
policy for one and as a matter of law in
our country and certainly as a matter of
cultural practice so why are white
people giving to these universities
often it's white liberals who are
donating anyway that's a very
bad white people should not be giving
money to institutions that explicitly
hate white people that's crazy what
about Christians these universities are
almost all extremely anti-christian
Christians should pull their funding why
on Earth are we giving money to
anti-christian
organizations all these groups are very
anti-male in the name of feminism they
attack men they say men are toxic and M
why are men giving money to these
organizations all of these groups
promote all sorts of weird sex stuff
they're explicitly anti-h heterosexual
they're anti-family they're
anti-marriage why are normal people in
normal marriages with normal sexual
practices why are they giving money to
these groups let's all take a lesson
from Ron Lauder here Ron Lauder being
extremely involved in Jewish activism is
obviously keenly tuned in to what's
going on in the Israel Palestine
conflict he says I'm pulling my money
because you're not being nice to the
Jews yeah we should apply that principle
to so many other identity categories and
we don't do that but we certainly should
it is suicide to me when I see
conservatives giving money to these
extremely leftist
organizations and it applies to any
number of categories of identity groups
hey cut hey yeah you got to ring the
bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel see you next time